welcome to this video playing AG ed from
France very frequent opponent how many
16 games try the number playing the
Kings Indian oops earlyish of g5 it's
not very common normally I think it's
belief that this should give like pretty
good counter play amazing the bishop is
in fact quite misplaced tab on the one
on a straw
yeah we should be a six simply on yeah
we should be a success Queen a six by
done preventing castling and Queenie 2
i'm not sure that he wants to play yeah
but it's both interesting actually I
mean I don't really have not worried
about Queen age six after we should
takes f6 but EF sometimes as f5 but I
guess it's more important here to have
the bishop sorry just just takes it AB
and immediately of course I don't know I
tend to think about those things but
then I'm also losing on time quite often
um ok so I must take this now yep there
is no way to avoid this and now we will
be aight i guess yeah on 95 it's both
both interesting probably 95 s is more
dangerous with 93 coming ok 93 on this
also look patr we ate also makes lots of
sense intending night c4 and route
between mu p 2 is the immediate threat
on 93 whatever it's it's both very
strong be 393 king be 1c for this is at
least a very strong attack um yeah c4
immediately can castle and this is this
i shouldn't do what else there is also
look be four
also quite nice but ok yeah let's make
sure he can really not castle and then
c4 is the next myth pretty much
regardless what is playing I'm going to
play c4 I want there be rock into play
so hard to tell where where where should
the King go I wonder I also can just
take be 3 by the way I just recognized
that just taking b3 it should be quite
good Yavin intending rugby to
immediately and threatening all kinds of
stuff if it takes it Queen a1 and okay
this this is falling apart already
yeah i know i mean yeah i know i'm
telling this over and over again I don't
understand sometimes why they play a
play stuff so quickly those very
committal moves that that see you not
yeah where you cannot recover if there's
something wrong okay so night f2 is okay
rook see three years okay what is the
best tell ya it's it's looking it's
looking nice in any case but taking a
night f2 looks a bit bit too more too
much of trades for me if I take here I
keep can give the check actually here
check King II to Queen takes e4 it's
also totally now yeah okay let's do this
one of the one of the good lines check
Quincy 2nite f 2 wins the rook gee I can
take careful yeah I have night f4 here
this was my my idea check picking up all
kinds of material check check here and
yeah what's what's quickest now 93 maybe
on check maybe probably there are many
ways
if it goes to the default plain night
after winning the rook yeah and hear
what keywords what's good here Quincy
for is certainly not bad Luke be aid
time morning who I'm actually down on
time this is also why is playing on I
was really asking herself why isn't here
just resigning this thing but okay I
didn't really see that I was so much
behind on the clock Queen d3i take a to
check um the snow is no medium I'm
probably just a stupid to see it better
yeah I'm taking I'm taking the Queen
white resigns yeah it really already
played this super quickly I mean I don't
don't know why here in this position
it's obviously critical for white you
cannot castle and really must consider
carefully to not get blown out of the
water and yeah you just played this all
very quickly by the way just just to
mention the computers recommendations
night to g1 and night g2e to I think
maybe those kind of moves is what you
should try you can try Queenie to for
example but this this really leads to a
very good compensation yeah something
like this with Luke p8 coming you can
try that as right it's not much fun to
play but you can try it's only a slight
edge for black according to the engine
yeah this I don't know I mean I don't
think that you can survive this yeah
computer is giving a black win already
it's simply too much you cannot castle
and I have got our pieces out after this
I think very tough to defend
it's above minus one not not a loss but
well after that it's a loss i guess
lucrative one is a better defense but so
very good yeah night sea floor ok check
can't hear the computer gives skinny too
yeah maybe maybe you can can check the
computer for example gives this is only
minus 0.7 maybe you can can can survive
this but it's not funny ok this happened
and now this one yeah I certainly had to
have a quicker way yes but check when
windows even I guess check this picked
up check lots of material and check here
there's some check this is a check I
made even checkmate not just the Queen
yeah it's very difficult those kind of
positions that are being called like you
know especially with this bishop on h4
this is often a problem problem for them
for white as it is somewhat off site in
terms of defending the Queen side so
it's very often not a good idea to have
the bishop there okay thanks for
watching